[Music]
kurt is in memphis hey kurt welcome to
the ramsay show
hey dave hey rachel thanks for having me
sure what's up um
well first i want to thank you so much
for all you've done thanks for the total
money makeover my wife and i have been
able to overcome some substantial
obstacles and eliminate 91 000 of debt
from way to go to 2020. awesome yes sir
we uh we still have our mortgage but
we've experienced a ton of financial
freedom after learning that debt
after that debt we
started to save up our cash and we have
35 000 an emergency fund and a high
yield savings account good for you um
but after that i got a little reckless
and i started putting our extra money
into an individual investment account
where i've been picking individual
stocks like alibaba chegg facebook
netflix
and
a bunch of those are down right now
but i do think they'll paint out long
term
we have about 20 000 in that account you
know another ten thousand just recently
into a series i bond
um so my take-home pay is about or our
take-home pay it's about 6100 a month
guaranteed and we at least have a
thousand left over each month after
putting 15 percent into our retirement
uh the problem is both of our vehicles
have 165 000 miles on them and we're
considering having a third child and at
some point
a minivan is going to be needed i'm a
little bit worried about used car prices
and i want to wait as long as i can
but the money for that van that we have
saved up is in individual stocks right
now and the series i've on that extra
thirty thousand
um i've considered whether we should use
our emergency phone for the car and just
let that stuff sit
i've got a job that's super stable
about as stable as it can get
i just i don't know what i should do
about that and whether i should start
putting my extra money towards a
mortgage
or if i should start saving that too in
case this is not this is exactly why we
tell people not to buy individual stocks
right that's exactly why
i know and at this point i've done it
and they're sitting on my heart i get
that it's water under the bridge but the
the first part of this we have to
address is never do this again
it's not cool you did not beat the
system it kicked your butt up around
your neck
that's why you're calling it
okay
you violated a principle here of
diversification and you started screwing
around thinking you were too smart doing
single stocks that you got your butt
kicked
now first we got to own that
okay i'm not picking on you i just don't
want you to ever go back here again now
if you agree with that
and you say i'm never going back you
don't have to agree with me this is for
your purposes you got to decide this you
don't have to i'm not i don't need your
agreement you can decide you do whatever
you want to do okay i'm just i want to
help you from this point forward now
that you're in the mess now if you say
okay i made a mistake because i took too
much risk playing with these single
stocks and i got my butt kicked and i'm
never doing that again now what do i do
well you get rid of them tomorrow
because every day you keep them it's
like you bought them again
meaning you think you st you're still
thinking you can hang on and win they're
going to be okay over time they're going
to be okay over time the stock market is
going to be okay over time not your
little portfolio
your little portfolio may still get its
butt kicked as the stock market recovers
i don't know
because you've got a handful of stocks
and you know
you're just
there's all kinds of studies that go the
individual person playing single stocks
can they it's like 90 of the time does
not even keep up with what the stock
market does
you always come in below the market
and it's because not because you're dumb
it's because you're not diversified
enough number one and number two
uh
that lack of safety then catches you
here uh because one or two little you
know you got six stocks two of them go
down it could take they can tank the
returns on the whole portfolio when
you've got 200 stocks and five of them
go down or six of them go down it
doesn't tank the portfolio stock so what
would i do if i woke up in your shoes i
would cash out the i bonds dumb
investment i would cash out the stocks
dumb investment immediately i'd put it
in a pile and i'd start linking thinking
about buying a car
okay
and stop doing this stuff that's what i
would do but you knew that you knew i
wouldn't do it when you called here you
already knew that the stuff we don't
tell you to do you know what would i do
if i woke up in bitcoin and bitcoin is
now what it's off 60 something percent
now from last september
so if you had a hundred thousand dollars
in there you've lost sixty thousand
dollars in bitcoin
and you bitcoin people been ragging me
threatened to burn my house down because
i said you were idiots
and and look how smart you are now
okay
and it wasn't because i hate bitcoin
it's because i hate stuff that is
unproven because it kicks your butt
and now what would i do if i owned
bitcoin if i'd put 100 000 in bitcoin
and i was you know what would what
should you do you should get out
tomorrow because it it may get better it
may get worse but it's still the same
stupid investment that it was last fall
it's just now you're you're in a
situation where warren buffett said when
the tide goes out you can tell who is
skinny dipping
when you're stupid is tr stress tested
it's it comes up stupid and and i'm not
fussing at you dude i'm just fussing at
all of us because i i did the exact same
stupid stuff when i was
in my 20s
and i put i put like 5000 bucks in this
gold thing this uh gold futures thing
this buddy of mine had a a guy he had a
guy he got you a guy as soon as you've
got a guy you know that you're backing
right about lose your butt soon somebody
says i got a guy that he had hit gold he
had picked out the gold option uh mark
and if you hit it you'd take 5 000 bucks
and make 50 grand
okay and he had hit it 11 out of the
last 11 periods oh wow
he was a genius yeah until the 12th one
when i put in five thousand dollars and
this genius right here so watch let me
tell you what happens if you don't make
the mark if you hit the mark the five
becomes fifty if you don't make the mark
it becomes zero ah
zero you know it would be a [ __ ]
domino
kurt so yes cash it out tomorrow buy the
minivan i would go with the honda
odyssey it's great fan from personal
experience uh but number two a funny
segment james would be all the the dumb
investments i've done like i was we had
a friend who will be unnamed about this
is my last this was probably it's when
winston kind of first got married so
it's been 12 years or so so we had a
friend and he was
he was like hell but oh can i say that
you're too late you did
hell bent on the dinari
oh my losing value and he's like you've
got to get into the dinari market you've
got to get into the iraqi diner and and
it was like i don't know he put a couple
hundred bucks in he was like literally
this is gonna be three million in in a
year when the when the iraqi government
collapsed he had this whole like
political he had figured it out through
it
and it wasn't there's the bitcoin of the
iraq war i get yeah yeah so anyways but
it did i i know yeah the dinar the iraqi
dinar yeah yeah that was a big thing
again but it'd be a funny segment for
people to call in and say hey here we
need to do a stupid tax hour again there
you go stupid butt stuff i have done
that has cost me money that's stupid tax
i'll lead off i'll tell you all the
stupid stuff i've done because i've done
a bunch of it that's why i'm so
passionate about this because it hurts
too much to me works it's hard for the
money and then it evaporate because i'm
stupid
i hate it when i'm stupid because it
costs money
i don't like it
[Music]
this is the ramsey show